hi I'm Erik Bosse and aventures in games
marketing strategies seems to be to
reveal as little as possible and I get
it
you got psychos like me on YouTube
analyzing and Mark Ruffalo's pupil
dilation that's a secret
he's always blabbing the main thing
missing from the limited footage that
we've seen is the subject that's really
been the focus of our in-game
speculation what the endgame itself will
be the epic comeback strategy for the
Avengers but I think that focus on the
victory Drive has caused us to overlook
the very real possibility that as bad as
things are currently for the Avengers
they could still get way worse and if
you pay close attention to these
trailers and clues or the filmmakers
it's actually starting to look likely
that the Avengers will fail again
spoiler warning the cases theory or
anything else I say ends up being right
everyone's your life okay this question
first entered my mind when we began
noticing some inconsistencies in the
in-game footage the recent trailer the
post-credits scene after Captain Marvel
specifically characters like cap and
Natasha cap appears in both clean-shaven
and bearded varieties and that's hair
appears in the short blonde cut that she
had an infinity war a longer blond braid
undone with her natural red flushing out
the blonde and that longer red tied in a
new braid of course there's always a
possibility of time travel or multiverse
happen around but the simplest
explanation to me is that these events
of in-game will take place over a long
period of time like not simply opening
title card six months later but some
events taking place shortly after that
oh snap and other story events that take
place much later Avengers in game is
rumored to be three hours long that's a
lot of story so I think we can expect
that this plot will have to be
structured in phases much like it was in
past Russo brothers Marcus McFeely
movies Winter Soldier Civil War infinity
war with opening setbacks shifting
tactics and twists and when it comes to
the opening act of endgame the
screenwriter hinted that the first act
would quote come from a darker place and
Marvel head Kevin Feige has suggested
that the marketing for the film would
only show the first 15 minutes of the
movie roughly combine those clues with
the fact that the end game trailers do
reveal some shots of characters in some
kind of battle cap tightening its shield
and gritting his teeth Nebula rock and
war machine appear to be in a similar
setting if we take Kevin Feige at his
word
this isn't the major Layton movie climax
event game then this could be early in
the film and it'd be kind of surprising
to see something this dramatic that
early in the film wouldn't it
Feige also revealed recently that the
original idea was to feature the snap
not at the end of infinity war but in
the first act of endgame of course they
ended up making a snap a cliffhanger
between movies but I still think they
intend on end game opening with some
major defeat some darker place that the
Avengers still don't emerge victorious
from leaving them in a state of
depression for months and months long
enough for black widows hair dyed washed
out so what could in game's opening
defeat look like well the cast and
filmmakers have implied that some
characters will feel more Restless than
others
Scarlett Johansson has said nad is
looking for answers it seemed to finish
the job and something with cap whom
we've seen in in game trailers refusing
to move on and filmmakers have
acknowledged he played a relatively
lesser role in Infinity Ward to set up a
more active charge and endgame and the
first trailer had that particularly
desperate line from cap this is good
marks to you I know it is cuz I don't
know what I'm gonna do if it doesn't and
then there's Thor whom the screenwriters
have said is feeling a lot of remorse
for not going for the head Thor was
particularly excited to meet Captain
Marvel in the recent trailer dialogue
physical and maybe that's because he
sees her as a quick-fix
a badass warrior who could potentially
break Infinity stones
so let's go right now these characters
might be more eager than the others to
chase down Thanos and give him a thumpin
even if it wouldn't really work I've
speculated that these battle shots of
cap could be untighten to that new home
planet that band have settled down and
after infinity war these Avengers could
be a vengeance torch and thanasis farm
oh I just planted that sorghum
but this rushed vengeance attempt could
lead to further humiliation explain what
that could look like in just a second
but before I continue thanks to raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
it's an amazing mobile game probably the
most immersive experience you'll find on
a smartphone or in this case a tablet
device we really should be comparing it
to the biggest PC and console titles but
this game is totally free raid has all
the features that you would expect from
a brand
RBG title an amazing storyline awesome
3d graphics giant phosphites pvp battles
and hundreds of champions to collect and
customize but i never expected to get
this level performance out of a mobile
game honestly look how crazy the level
of detail is on these champions each of
this beard pieces has a hair tie rain is
getting big real fast so jump on this
and get a huge head start there's also a
special launch tournament coming up with
crazy in-game prizes and real-life
physical prize packs so go down to the
description and download raid only
through my links to get 50,000 silver
immediately and a free epic champion as
part of the new player program courtesy
of the developer team see you there okay
back to how a rushed payback attempt by
the Avengers could backfire it's
possible that Thanos could simply snap
again dust away another half of the
remaining universe down to 1/4 to punish
the Avengers for being sore losers kind
of like a judge it throws more and more
prison time at a defendant who tries to
fight back and I sentence you to 20 days
for that and if you say anything else
I'm gonna add 20 days for everything you
say you forty days you again sixty go
yourself a year your mama
ten years sorry I know we stayed on that
a bit long I slippery watching it but
imagine with Bannos now we're down to
25% Oh still plating 12.5% Oh still more
6.25% like he just keeps tapping and
stamping and snap until all that's left
is like half of Thor's new eyeball one
of the screenwriters was quoted recently
saying Thanos is the one true master of
the stones that others don't understand
their true power how to use them and
that Thanos can reset as many times as
it'll take requiring the Avengers to try
to keep away one stone at a time this
quote implies a recurring series of
comeback attempts each one reset by
Thanos perhaps using the same kind of
time loop Doctor Strange used on
Dormammu except here it could be the
Avengers failing over and over perhaps
leading to the death toll climbing
higher and higher losing even more
heroes like Captain Marvel maybe further
wearing down the Avengers resolved until
Thanos forces them to just move on
because this three-hour epic film can't
just be like 10 minutes of the Avengers
wallowing and post snap defeat and
Scott Lang bursts in with a tiny
building and a bunch of nonsense about
quantum physics half of which is
probably getting wrong anyway all of a
set up one long mission that'll take
like two hours and 50 minutes to
complete know there's probably gonna be
debate over what the right tactic is
Messi attempts that fail over make
things worse before they finally reach
the correct course look the recess in
the m's have proven to be really good
about defying our expectations of the
past hiding darker twists that are
impossible to predict from trailer
footage alone like we all thought when a
soldier would simply be about cap
realizing a super assassin was actually
his old pal Bucky
but twist it also revealed that Hydra
was behind shield all this time we
thought civil war would be a debate over
superhero registration foot twist it was
actually a much more personal fight over
Starks parents and we thought infinity
war would be a struggle to stop Thanos
from gathering all the stones which
maybe 1 or 2 heroes would die put twist
half him did which I guess is exactly
what happened in the comics but still
felt like a twist so I think we're in
store for a similar dark twist and end
game remember in Tony Stark's nightmare
an age of Ultron it wasn't the
characters who dusted an infinity war
who were dead it was the original six
any of whom could still eat it an
in-game we may expect this movie to
involve some complicated sci-fi strategy
to undo the snap but it could actually
open with the most surprising twist of
all that the rock bottom that we thought
we hit a me even the rock bottom yet so
here's my question which major character
do you think is the most likely to die
in the first act of endgame comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ ee boss and
subscribe to the rockstars for all of
our Avengers theories that statistically
speaking will probably be wrong bye
[Music]